breaking and developing news sky news
understands the dame cressida dick the
commissioner of the metropolitan police
is to leave her job we'll get the latest
on that right now with our political
correspondent joe pike and joe
dame crest has been under heavy
criticism for some time now not least by
the mayor of london certainly sadiq khan
earlier this week saying that she was on
notice that he wanted to see
some change some saw that as him rolling
the pitch ahead of a possible uh
dismissal dame crested today in a radio
phone and said you had absolutely no
intention of leaving her post but
tonight we have a statement from the
mayor of london confirming she is
departing sadiq khan said last week i
made clear to the commissioner the scale
of the change i believe is urgently
required to rebuild the trust and
confidence of londoners in the met and
to root out the racism sexism homophobia
bullying discrimination and misogyny
that still exists of course he was
talking about that because of that
really damaging report about the culture
within charing cross police station he
continues in this statement i am not
satisfied with the commission's response
on being informed of this dame crested
dick has said she will be she will be
standing aside it is clear the only way
to start to deliver the scale of the
change required is to have new
leadership right at the top of the met i
would like to thank her for a 40 years
service he talks about how dame crested
was the first woman the first
openly gay person
to lead the force the biggest most
important police force in the country we
understand that there will be a period
of transition she will remain in her
post for a short period whatever that is
so a successor can be appointed she does
have two deputies sir stephen house used
to run police scotland and sir craig
mckee now those would be obvious
candidates but of course they've been
part of the same much criticized
organization and some including
the mayor may want somebody with a
fresher outside perspective and joe does
the government have to have a say in
this decision as well what is the formal
process
they certainly do uh home secretary
pretty patel is ultimately the person
who needs to
sign off this sadiq khan of course has
oversight of the met police and the
commissioner but he does need uh pretty
patel to approve the decision that
clearly is what has happened today we're
likely to hear i'm sure from the home
secretary and the mayor of london uh in
the coming hours but certainly this
seems to be
the end of the road a sad end to an
otherwise reasonably successful 40-year
career for dame crester dick but the bad
headlines and the scandals did
happen again and again and again
most recently of course all these
reports about uh the culture within her
police force but previously the sarah
everard vigil last year and seemingly
the police mishandling of that after of
course a met police officer uh did uh
kidnap and murder uh sarah at everard
but some also critics might look at this
decision and question it i think it's
fair to say that she was in a very
politically difficult position at this
moment because of course her force is
investigating the prime minister and the
key people who live and work around him
at the moment so in the midst of that
investigation the person in charge of
that whole force has been taken out
absolutely can't of course as a labour
mayor pretty patel is a conservative
home secretary so i suppose you could
argue though this decision has been a
cross-party one but something has
changed rather rapidly because she was
coming formally to the end of her term
wasn't she this year but that was
extended not too very long ago for
another two years exactly she was
originally appointed to a five-year term
from april 2017 to april 2022 so just a
couple of months off that but towards
the end of last year pretty patel did or
offer her a two-year extension that
would have taken cressida dick's uh
contract uh running the met as the
commissioner of the police of the
metropolis
to april 2024 obviously that has not
happened the pressure on uh sadiq khan
to act has clearly been too much and
she's gone joe uh just as we're speaking
here we just got a statement uh from
the commissioner from cressida dick just
coming in i'll read it out it says
it is with huge sadness that following
contact with the mayor of london today
it's clear that the mayor no longer has
sufficient confidence in my leadership
to continue he has left me no choice but
to step aside as commissioner of the
metropolitan police service
at his request i have agreed to stay on
for a short period to ensure the
stability of the met and its leadership
while arrangements are made for a
transition to a new commissioner
undertaking this role as a servant of
the people of london and the uk has been
the greatest honor and privilege of my
life throughout my career i've sought to
protect the people of this wonderful
thriving and diverse city there have
been many tough calls many challenges
the 2017 terrorist attacks the grenfell
fire difficult protest the pandemic the
murder of serving officers i'm
incredibly proud she says my team and
all they have achieved since day one
tackling violence in all its forms has
been my number one priority we continue
to see teenagers murdered on our streets
and every attack is a tragedy
but we are delivering and overall
violence is down the met is bucking the
national trend we are achieving
remarkable results